this section we're going to talk about
two very basic operations on vectors
so far actually we haven't done anything
with vectors uh you you've met a couple
that have special names like ones
zero unit vectors in
in the last section we talked about
examples of vectors right but so far we
haven't actually done
anything with them okay so in this
section what we're going to talk about
is addition and scalar multiplication so
that's these are operations on vectors
okay
so vector addition if you've got two
vectors of the same size
you can add them and we're going to
heavily overload the notation we're just
going to use the same old plus that
you'd use to write two plus three
so the difference is when plus appears
between two vectors
it's really referring to vector addition
not to of course
the addition of two numbers okay and the
way you do it
it's pretty straightforward um you just
add the corresponding entries so here's
an example there's two three vectors
this one
and this one and that's that's their
so-called sum
okay and the way you get it
is you just do it entry by entry so for
example in the second entry we add seven
and two and sure enough we get nine so
that's how you add add vectors
okay you can also subtract vectors too
so that's that's uh
that's the idea now we'll shortly
see practical applications of this but
for the moment this is just like this
these are the rules of the game
this is what it means to add two vectors
let me add
one thing to that you cannot add vectors
of different sizes
okay so that if you attempt to if you
say what is
you know this uh you know one zero minus
one
um the answer is it has no meaning that
that
it has absolutely no meaning right you
might as well write something like zero
divided by zero
okay um so just can't be done
so that's an important thing to remember
oh and i should say that
all languages that either allow you know
support
vectors will allow you to add them
there'll be something in fact very often
it's just the symbol plus so okay
um so there's some properties of vector
addition
um and let's see what some of them are
um well it's commutative
to commute means that you can switch the
order of two things
like one thing first or second and it's
the same that sort of means to commute
and so we write that this way it says a
plus b equals b plus a
um now i want to say something about
some of these equations here and in fact
it's about the power of
notation right um yeah when you look at
this
you know that this equation is true when
a and b are numbers
basically says you know addition of num
addition
of numbers is uh commutative if i add
two plus three it's the same as adding
three plus two
uh so um that's the commutative property
right
um but here uh the difference is these
are vectors
um and so what's happening here is both
plus is a special plus it's the plus
between two vectors
and even equals has been overloaded here
because it's basically saying that the
left and right side are
are vectors right not not numbers um
now the other thing is that a lot of
these things are just really
easy to look at and go yeah whatever i
mean come on and just
glaze over it i mean they look good
right like i don't know
um here uh if i add two if i had two
things
and then then add that to a third it's
the same as if i added the first to the
sum of the
second and third right this is true if
abc are numbers
but it's also true if they're vectors
right um
here's one uh a plus zero equals zero
plus a equals eight well you kind of
look at those equations you're like well
what else could it be what else could a
plus zero be it's got to be a
right so it looks good but it's actually
saying something and actually this is a
great example
where uh we can say something that's
kind of interesting here uh
first of all we here zero is a zero
vector and it's got to be the same size
as a so
a is a five vector meaning it's got a
dimension of five
then this zero is it's five zeros
stacked on top of each other and a
vector that's that's that's what that is
right and we determine that from the
context because it doesn't make sense to
add
a to another vector unless they have the
same size and a has size five
so whatever you add to it better have
the same size so that's the idea here
um okay so uh
so this is a this is an example where we
can work out the size of zero
from the context okay oh here's one if
you subtract the vector from itself you
get zero
now that this is very important that's
the zero vector
now i want to say just a couple things
about properties like this right that
um so the first is uh and
this one is important it's easy to let
your eyes just
glaze over things like this i mean they
look good that's the point i mean that's
the point of good
you know a minus a is zero well duh what
did you think it was going to be
um what's very important is to force
yourself until you really have
internalized these
to realize that very elementary looking
notation it looks like the kind of
notation
you know the stuff you were writing when
you were in like first grade or
something like that
but this time these are not numbers it
the plus the minus the equals
everything here is actually means
between vectors
so make sure that you're you know this
is sort of i guess i
put it this way it's mindful equation
reading
don't just read and go yeah whatever
okay you look at it and you ask
what does it mean is that a three
vectors at a five vector what you know
that kind of thing
and you just you know just process it
slowly so that's the first thing i'd ask
you to do
okay um the second has to do with action
so somebody actually has to show these
right like
i can't just say this and say well okay
actually uh in the
you know whatever late uh late 18th
century in
math real math had not really started by
then i mean they knew a lot of stuff
but it was kind of mixed together with
theology and all sorts of stuff and
nobody had the idea that you actually
had to show something it was more like
well
what else would it be or didn't have
that idea but these days and these days
means
for the last 200 years or so uh the way
we do it is you define something
and then when you assert something you
have to i mean if you
you either show it's true or basically
no one's gonna believe you okay
so some somebody somewhere has to
actually show that for any vector a
if you subtract a you get zero now what
i will say about
showing this is it's interesting to sort
of think about one or two
or whatever but no more than that
because they get exceedingly boring
but it isn't it's interesting to know
that i mean somebody has to do this but
anyway let's just do an example i mean
this is really pretty dumb
but let's just do an example let's
subtract 2 1
minus 3. uh from that let's subtract you
know
one minus three okay and we're just
going to blindly follow we're gonna go
two minus two
and we're gonna go two minus two and
we're gonna get zero we're gonna go one
minus one and that's zero two
and minus three minus minus three that's
zero so
there you go okay well apparently this
holds for these this specific
vector a i mean that's kind of silly but
that's the idea
so the way you would show this in
general is you'd actually say well we'd
write
a let's do three vectors right
we would do this and then we'd write it
out in component you know in its
coefficients like that
and then we would say that's a1 minus a1
a2 minus a2 a3 minus a3
and that in turn would be zero zero zero
okay and then there would be the whole
the whole stack of arguments now
these are uh often to be honest with you
verifying some of these uh these
properties is just
incredibly boring so um if you take a
real
if you take a real heart if you take a
math class on this
you will likely be forced to do it but
the good news that's the bad news the
good news it's not that bad the
good news you do it once in your life
and that's it and then after that
once you've done it you'd never do it
again so okay
all right let's talk about what uh
adding so far i mean really so far
in addition we've just talked about kind
of what it means
right uh it means you just you add the
corresponding entries it's pretty
okay that's what it is but now what
we're going to do
uh is we're going to talk about what
does it mean in various
practical contexts and that's oh that's
actually always super interesting and
that's kind of the point of this class
actually
so okay um all right
if you have displacements right so
here's a vector
a which represents a displacement it
says move you know
five units to the right and one unit up
that's what it that's what a means
here's b it's another displacement it's
a displacement that says
please move one unit to the left that
goes this way
and it says and three units up okay
and then here it turns out that the
when you add those two vectors up the
what you will get is the displacement
obtained by
doing one of the displacements and then
the other okay now what's cool here is
here
it means you could go a and from there
you go
up here uh to b and this would be a plus
b by the way you could do the same
you could you could we could show
cumulativity here uh
in the sense that b if i did first i
went to b
then i would go to a okay and that would
show that that would be b
plus a and sure enough it would be the
same as a plus b so this is the idea is
you add displacements
right so um so it says
you know if you start from uh you know
home base and i say go
one kilometer one kilometer east and two
kilometers north
and then i say let's let's let after
that from there
please go you know negative two
kilometers east or whatever uh
that's two kilometers west and one
kilometer north
uh you would add them and you'd get the
final displacement from your base camp
or something like that so that's the
idea and this is a very traditional idea
of you know vectors this is kind of the
picture that you see
from you know whatever high school
physics or something okay
now uh vectors i mean
vector subtraction is actually very
interesting because it can be used to
connect uh positions to displacements
and very typically
the displacement from a point q that
that's the coordinates of q
to a point p is actually p minus q it's
it's actually where you land minus where
you started so for example
um if if that's a vector there and q is
given
q the entries of q give the coordinates
of q here's p and it says if we
move from q to p our displacement vector
is p minus q and that's the blue vector
shown
shown here so that's a that's also a a
a connection uh and this is you know
when people
first hear about vectors it's usually in
a context like this in a
vector calculus or a physics or
mechanics class a basic one
okay now we can also
multiply uh we can there's some types of
multiplication that you can carry out
with vectors we're going to talk about
several of them before the course is
over
but a very important one is that you can
multiply a scalar
remember that that's a just a fancy word
for a number
and a vector and so here if i have a
scalar beta
and an n vector a
then you can multiply them and and you
write it this way you literally you just
juxtapose them you put them next to each
other the two symbols right so
by the way you don't use times and you
don't use dot
okay those are reserved symbols also
those are kind of for children to be
honest i mean
you know people who write whatever well
okay it's fine here you can write that
that's fine
but you don't write that over you don't
write that with vectors
in fact times and dot actually have a
different meaning
with vectors we're going to get there
don't worry uh
so here the the notation is you just
juxtapose them um
oh and sometimes people put the vector
uh
put the vector in front and the scalar
afterwards right so
um for some weird you know this is just
pure convention
it means the same thing but this people
this is weird i don't know why you don't
see it that much but
anyway that's but everyone would
understand it if they saw it
now the question is what's the meaning
what's the semantics of this well
semantics is pretty simple it says when
you take a scalar
beta and you multiply it by vector you
get a vector it comes back same size
and it's really kind of simple what it
says is just please scale
every entry in that vector by the code
by the coefficient by the scalar
or the number beta so that's written out
here
okay so let's do a quick example let's
multiply
uh minus 2 that's our scalar or number
times the 3 vector 196
okay and you just you multiply each of
the answers by minus 2. so you get minus
2 minus 18 minus 12. there you go
there's that
so that's uh it's pretty exciting no
it's not this is extremely boring
but this is just the this is just the
mechanics this is the plumbing
this is this is what it means to
multiply two so far it has no interest
no meaning
when we look at applications it starts
getting interesting okay
so that's the idea okay
um let's mention some properties of
scalar vector multiplication and things
like that
so here's one and these equations you
know you have to be super duper careful
i mean at the very least
what you need to do is look at these
equations and understand
what it's saying uh because of just a
handful of symbols here can say
very sophisticated things and you need
to be uh
mindful of that right because that's
what that's what good powerful notation
is right when i write down like
five characters right and it has it's
packing huge meaning into something
that's when you got to be on your toes
it's that's that's good notation right
um
okay so and these would be things like i
don't know uh here's one
that this says it's associative so here
we have to be super duper careful
let's imagine that a is a 10 vector
okay and of course here
beta and gamma are scalars so they're
real numbers
right real number is just uh i guess
it's just a number okay
it's yeah it's a real number that's it
okay
um so then let's go through and very
carefully analyze
this um it's not saying something
spectacular
right it's saying it's saying basically
that
if i have two numbers and this one when
i put the parentheses here
i see the i see the juxtaposition of
beta and gamma now that only means one
that's multiplication
um but in this case the multiplication
is between two real numbers and we know
what that is that's just like that's
what you learned when you were
you know in uh in grade school right you
multiply the two numbers
um so so what's in this this
parenthesis is a number it's the product
of beta and gamma
then that is stuck in front of a but a
is a 10 vector
so now what we see is this looks like a
number
times a 10 vector now we know what that
is that's a 10 vector and it's the 10
vector obtained by taking every
entry in the vector and multiplying it
by the scalar the number in front
okay now on the right hand side we see
something
it's actually different right on the
right hand side we see
gamma which is a number times a now
gamma is a number
a is a vector gamma times a is therefore
a vector so that's a 10 so what's in the
parentheses here is a is a vector it's a
10 long vector
then we call the multiplication
again sorry i'm using some computer
science language there but
then what we do is we carry out
multiplication by the scalar beta
again and that's uh that's it so
actually
and the result on the right hand side is
again a 10 vector and it has to be
because this equals here doesn't make
sense unless the left and right hand
side are vectors of the same size
and they are in this case so that's the
that's the basic
uh that's the basic idea uh here uh
with with all of this so so you know
please look at some of these equations
they look silly
it's hard to focus but just go through
and make sure you understand what every
single thing
like you know which like i could ask a
question like
here you go what plus is that
plus is overloaded plus could mean
between numbers as in two plus three
it could be between two vectors right so
which is it
well in this case if i said that b is
also a ten vector
um this plus just happens to be the plus
that adds two vectors together
right um how about this plus right there
well that plus you look at what it's
adding it's left and right it's
so-called arguments
those are numbers so this plus is the
plus that you knew about
when you were a kid it's it's it's two
plus three equals five that's
that's what that plus is so anyway i
would recommend
uh that you you know these equations
look
super innocent but be sure you
understand them perfectly i mean really
you should audit it make sure you get it
because it's very easy to get into
trouble this is very powerful notation
okay you can
combine the two concepts of scaling or
scalar multiplication
and addition and you get something which
is pretty much at the very center of
this course
and it's the idea of a linear
combination and let me say what that is
a linear combination is this i give you
a list
of vectors m vectors of oh this is a
perfect example of
a notational ambiguity this is
absolutely standard throughout
all branches of mathematics applied
mathematics and many other fields
so it's not quirky to just linear
algebra or something like that and
what it is is here these are m
different vectors okay so
uh as opposed to if i just walk up here
in the street and i say a is a vector
then a3 means that the it means
literally the third entry in a and it's
a number
so i for example it minus might be this
okay
now here in this case
a3 does not a3 is the third vector in my
in my series of vectors that's what it
means right so
these could be the feature vectors of m
patients that are admitted to the
hospital okay
so for example in that case a3 is a
feature vector
and it tells you about patient three
okay
that's that's that's the idea all right
back to our story
our story is that we've got these
vectors and we've got also a set of
m scalars so we're going to call this
beta one through beta m and it says if i
just simply
multiply a1 by beta1 you know a2 by
beta2 and so on and then add them up
that that second one was the vector
addition right
then that's called a linear combination
of the vectors
okay that's that's that's the idea and
it's a super important
uh concept oh here you would call betas
the coefficients in the linear
combination
um and it's it's not just a very
important concept it is essentially the
central concept in this course and for
that matter to be honest
a lot of others right so it's a very
basic idea
um and that's what it means um now
um the
these sometimes linear combinations have
special names right
like here's a here's a very common
example is when
the betas are positive let's suppose the
betas are positive
and they sum to one right
um then uh this
linear combination here is sometimes
called a
a weighted average or something like
that
um or another word for it is a convex
combination
that's because it connects to some
mathematic some other mathematics but
it's just called a weighted average or
something like that so
maybe an example that like this um if
you know anyway so that would be that
that's kind of yeah that'd be the
weighted
weighted average yeah okay um all right
so here's a very important identity it's
you have to look at it to make sure it
looks silly
and what it says is kind of goofy but
this is it it
makes sense it says this it says b is a
vector
and it says that it's it's equal to the
following here's a linear combination
of e1 through en remember these are the
unit vectors
so so it says b is b1 times e1 let's
just check this
for a very simple baby vector let's take
b equals two minus one that's a two
vector
and so according to this formula it says
that b is equal to
b one that's two times e one
plus um minus 1
times e2 okay so
okay let's let's let's check um that's
2 times e 1
right and then i'll just write it as
minus 0
1 like that okay and then because i've
run out of time
plan i ran out of space and have planned
poorly my
equation space i'll just do two
operations in one i'm going to multiply
this together i get 2 0 and i'm going to
subtract that and i get
2 and i get minus 1.
and sure enough that is the same as b
okay
so um so what this says is something i
mean it's kind of you
people can also make this sound weird in
mystical or something they would say
that
you know a vector is represented as the
sum of its coefficients times the unit
vectors
something like that but anyway it's it's
a this says less than you uh
than you think but i mean it's something
we're going to come back to a bunch of
times
okay that's a linear accommodation um
again so far
it means nothing to you uh or so far
until we look at applications and then
it starts getting
quite interesting um so here's one well
first we look just graphically
right um so if i have two vectors
rep you know a1 and a2 um then
i can form a linear combination let's
see how to form that visually
the linear combination point seven five
three quarters of a1 plus 1.582
well i start with a1 here i multiply it
by three quarters
now what that does is it simply shrinks
its length by 25 it multiplies it by
0.75
okay so that's this point here it had to
be point it had been going out well
this vector is in fact 4 0
and over here this vector is 3 0 which
is indeed 0.75 times this vector here
okay here's a2 which is 2 2
2 comma 2 that's another vector
and here what i can do is i'm going to
multiply that
by 1.5 and that would give me this
vector here
which would be the 3 3 vector right
because if you multiply 2 2 by
1.5 you get 3 3. okay and when i add
them together
i'm going to get this thing here okay so
uh this is a kind of a visual example of
what a linear combination
means and it's an important it's an
important figure that you should have in
your mind
okay um let's jump to finance
okay so in finance let's suppose we have
uh
this is going to be a super simple thing
we have three time periods
uh sorry four three time periods i'm
sorry these are three vectors
and these are cash flows okay so let's
analyze
a cash flow so let's look at the first
one and the periods could be
a year let's say and what it does is it
says
that this says this one says one
and let's assume that one here
one means a payment to you so this cash
flow says here's what it is
right now you get a dollar okay
um it says one year from now
uh you get minus 1.1 that means you pay
1.1 and in the third year zero
and so we can understand when you see
this vector you should be able to
understand it's a one dollar loan
from period one to period two with two
percent uh ten percent interest right
so what it is is you get a dollar that's
when you initiate the loan
and when you pay it back you have to pay
back the dollar plus 10
interest and that's minus 1.1 so that's
the idea and it has nothing to do with
period three
um at the same time when you see that
cash flow
that's a super interesting thing too it
means in period one you get nothing
but a year from now you get one dollar
and
two years from now we have we ask you to
pay 1.1
so that's a load that's a one dollar
loan from period two to period three
with 10 interest right so uh by the way
uh one of the things you're going to
want to do in this class is for all of
the applications we look at you're going
to want to be able to translate
the concepts and ideas we don't have
many of them yet right we have linear
combination
and stuff like that translate those to
the application
uh by the way every now and then it
either has no meaning or is silly
but often it's super interesting right
like so for example
we could write out you can write out
with the cash flow of a mortgage
is of a fully amortized mortgage right
you could
uh work out the cash flow for a bond
right in which case you'd get coupon
payments and then at the very end you'd
get the whole
you'd get not only the coupon final
coupon payment but you'd also get the
principal back
right so uh this comes up a lot all
right
back to our main story here our main
story is now to look at a linear
combination so
we're gonna look at a very specific one
just for fun um
so we're going to look at c1 that's this
this
literally this vector right here plus
1.1
times c2 that's this vector here
now when you do that it's really awesome
here's let's work out what you get
so c1 is 1 minus 1.10
there we go and then we go plus 1.1
times 0 1 minus 1.1
and let's see what we get well in the
first one
we get 1.1 times 0 is 0. so i get 1.
here i get minus 1.1 this one
plus 1.1 times 1. but that's zero
and then down here i get minus 1.1
squared right which is like minus 1.21
i think okay so that's
cool if i just asked you to
describe in words the cat what is that
cash flow vector
you would say i don't know it means this
it means i get a dollar
in the first period and then the second
period nothing happens
and in the third period though i have to
pay back the dollar
and 10 interest accrued twice that's why
you get it squared
and that's minus 1.21 so
um okay so this is cool and this is a
super basic concept in finance and a lot
of other stuff
you would say i mean this is a super
simple example but you would say here
that you have
we have replicated right a two-period
loan
right that's a two-period loan cash flow
i've replicated a two-period loan
from two one-period loans and i've done
it as a linear combination
you know c uh c1 plus 1.1 c2 so that's
that's kind of the idea and these are
concepts we'll we'll come back to them
later